[Music]
from the nation's capital the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research presents public policy forums a
series of programs featuring the
nation's top authorities presenting
their differing views on the vital
issues which confront us
today's topic revitalizing America what
are the possibilities in the classic
mythology of old Greece and Houma
ancient mariners feared twin monsters
Scylla and Charybdis Rock and whirlpool
garbed and the fantasies of the unknown
in the Straits of Messina between Sicily
in the toe of Italy they represented two
equally perilous alternatives neither of
which could be passed without
encountering and probably falling victim
to the other mythology deals with the
imaginary or fictitious with gods and
demigods and monsters that dwell in the
mind
those who chart the course of the
American ship of state in this new
decade do not deal with inventions of
the mind the monsters that they must
contend with are real facts of daily
life and the way ahead a tangle of
alternatives so complex and dangerous is
to kill the stoutest heart a safe course
must be plotted in defense the economy
Foreign Affairs energy government
regulation taxes health and social and
political processes and each must
succeed without falling victim to the
others to examine the course to take us
to safe harbor the way to a revitalized
America we have a highly expert panel to
my far right Congressman Newt Gingrich
Republican member of the House
Administration Public Works and
transportation committees to my
immediate right representative Richard B
Cheney White House chief of staff under
President Ford the new chairman of the
Republican policy committee in the House
and a member of the Interior and insular
Affairs committees to my immediate left
representative Richard a Gephardt member
of the Ways and Means and budget
committees
and appointed chief of task forces a new
position in Democratic Party leadership
in the house and to my far last
reference representative wife Fowler
Democrat a member of the powerful Ways
and Means Committee and the Select
Committee on Intelligence well to begin
gentlemen I would pose the same question
to each of you what are the most
critical policy issues the major
priorities in public policy
representative Cheney well I think Jon
that that first and foremost in the
standpoint of the Congress need the
issues we're gonna have to deal with in
the in the months and years ahead deal
very much for the economy it seems to me
we've reached a point in this country
where the rate of economic growth is
such that we no longer are able to do
either of two very important things one
to provide sufficient public revenues to
take care of our public responsibilities
not only in the domestic area but also
in terms of national defense and
secondly we are no longer able because
of the lack of vitality in our economy
to provide a real prospect for the
American people that their lives of
their children will be better than their
own that they can look forward to a
bright and optimistic future situation
of economic economic prosperity to come
and we've lost that bird or important
element representative Gephardt
certainly one would have to agree that
the economy has to be the dominant issue
upon it depends most everything in our
society and the economy has simply not
been working correctly for the past
eight to ten years and therefore the
Congress will be dominated by that issue
there are lots of sub issues that relate
to it energy being the most important
and in my view we will continue to
wrestle with that problem through the
rest of our lifetimes representative
generations thank the two major issues
that are going to affect us in the whole
deck of the 80s are one how do we
rebuild a sense of trust and dialogue in
our political structure so that people
have some sense that how they vote
matters and that what happens in the
elected process means something
and second how do we reopen the system
to new ideas I think that at every level
the what we're seeing are symptoms I
think that inflation and the decay of
productivity the decay of our defense
structure the decay of the bureaucracy
in some ways the collapse of Education
are all related to the fact that we are
increasingly muscle-bound in a system
that no longer is open either to
pragmatism or to new ideas represented
fouler well I would certainly agree with
with the specifics that my colleagues
have just mentioned I would also like to
tag on to what my Georgia colleague mr.
Gingrich has said I think that
overarching all of our public policy
decisions is the question of how we once
again ensure accountability and the
public knows that knows where that
accountability lies where it runs so if
they feel again that they are part of
the system I enter government by the
governor the other footnote to that has
not talked about very much I think we
will see that equally important as any
congressional decision that more and
more our lives in this country will be
determine the quality of our lives in
this country will be determined by the
caliber and the quality of international
agreements equally as much as domestic
legislation either emanating from the
Congress or from the White House right
the National Academy of Public
Administration a 29 member panel of
former cabinet members governor's labor
leaders members of the Congress calls
for a more strongly United and
disciplined Congress a greater capacity
for coordinated action by the President
and the Congress and for a higher level
of managerial ability throughout the
government than has been customary how
say you to that those recommendations as
a prescription for the future who would
like to start it well there are good
recommendations I think I have greater
hope for making the Congress more
willing to take on some of the
unpleasant decisions that I think have
to be made in the next 10 years and
to meet the problems we've discussed I
suppose I'm coming out a bit pessimistic
about our ability to achieve much
greater levels of competence and
managerial ability in the United States
government the federal level we do not
have a system that is a lot like the
Japanese system where the best and the
brightest desire public service at the
bureaucratic level we tend to not pay
wages that are commensurate with private
industry certainly today with the levels
of inflation so therefore I don't
foresee a time when our executive branch
our bureaucracy is going to be improved
a great deal Jimmy Carter talked about
that a lot most every president talks
about it talks about reorganization we
passed a major civil service reform act
it has yielded some good results but I
think on the whole we can't see much
positive happening I have a greater hope
that we will have a Congress that is
more accountable that's more willing to
take on some of the tough decisions that
we have to face I think in the past few
years we've seen for instance a budget
process
which hasn't yielded a great deal of
courage perhaps in fiscal discipline but
at least we've got a process in place
and hopefully in the years ahead it will
yield that kind of fiscal discipline
that I think so important I let me
differ a little bit with a dick I I
think Congress has been a big part of
the problem I'd have to argue and that
with in recent years Power has been
diffused within the body to the extent
that that Speaker of the House
leadership of either party is is unable
to deliver when a commitments made to
the president whatever his party might
be it's almost impossible to build
around a commitment by the leader the
kind of coalition that's required to
pass its program I think that one of the
fundamental problems has been the the
extent of which we placed restraints on
presidential authority over the last
several years we've been so consumed
with the trauma of water
in Vietnam that every time we've
tampered with the relationship between
the executive branch and the Congress
we've done so in a way that's designed
primarily to avoid future abuses of
power similar to those that are alleged
to have happened in the past we've been
concerned with the so called myth of the
imperial presidency and I don't think
there's any way we can address that the
public policy agenda that we all talked
about at the outset unless we really
talk about strong executive leadership
and that seems to me we've got to
restore some balance between the
Congress on one hand and the and the
executive branch on the other represent
[Music]
if I can descend from my good colleague
from Wyoming I think what we need is a
stronger Congress not a weaker that the
greatest danger of the Reagan
administration is that conservatives
will decide you can trust imperial
presidents as long as their right-wing
when their imperial that the great
problem has been and will continue to be
that we need a generation of social
invention that the old system has died
whether it's the big city machine or the
Rayburn Congress and that in the age of
television and jet aircraft and
computerized letters we have not yet
invented the working political system
that will govern us for the next half
century but that system I think if we're
gonna remain a free country will be
focused in the house and the Senate not
in the White House and that's one of our
major problems is that for 20 years now
we have focused on the wrong institution
to save this country and I think that
until we get back to that and things
like the invention of the task force
chairmanship that the Dick Gephardt has
I think are steps towards inventing a
more effective more mobile and more
fluid system it could I sure follow
under and ask this it's my sense also
that the Congress needs to do a much
better job of oversight and evaluation
people talk for years about sunset
legislation and the Congress doing a
better job of overseeing the
implementation of programs that it's
passed we aren't doing that yet I think
we'd all admit that we don't know
whether that will ever happen but don't
you agree that that has to happen or we
simply have to keep bumping along the
way we are we can't really I don't think
too
I asked Congress to authorize giant
programs to appropriate money for those
programs and then to step back and hope
that the executive branch does what it
wants done without knowing what's
happening without asking questions
without really day-to-day overseeing to
a large extent what is happening
that doesn't mean they tell them how to
run the department but it does mean they
have to understand how the law is being
implemented so they can either change
the law or get rid of it or get rid of
the program I certainly would agree that
we need to do a better job on evaluation
and oversight of the executive branch my
problem mode and speak the newts point
and follow up on yours to dick you serve
on the Budget Committee I think the
budget process has become a joke we're
absolutely as an institution incapable
of making the kinds of decisions that
the budget process seems to warn I don't
think the solution is going to be found
and giving Congress a bigger role than
they've had in the past it seems to me a
proper way to go would be for Congress
to go ahead and set that overall
spending ceiling but if we're unable to
make the hard decisions on program cuts
must delegate the authority to the
President to impound funds within
certain broad parameters that we might
establish he used to have that authority
it was used very effectively until the
Nixon administration at which time
because of Watergate Congress removed
that authority from him I don't think
the Congress is ever going to have the
courage to do anything about the
entitlement programs but with strong
executive leadership perhaps we can
begin to address that very fundamental
issue and you can't talk about
addressing the budgetary problems we
face and the economic problems we face
unless we really are willing to bite the
bullet on entitlement programs
I think dick that you agree the problem
with the budget process is that we all
vote for the popular programs unwilling
to stare a veteran in the face and say
no I'm not going to double you the
benefits for the 10th straight year and
go ahead and swell it up and then vote
against the final product that we have
swelled by our own hypocrisy and I just
don't see how turning that back to to
the president first of all I just don't
think it's possible under a Andalus
catalyst is less of a hypocrite than we
sometimes are representative Gingrich
I think the reason I like the budget
system and the fights that we had on the
budget is that it is the first real
attempt by the house to create a
parliamentary environment in which there
is some effort at some level to say here
we stand you can measure us on this vote
and this has an aggregate impact on the
whole system and until you can get to
those kind of tough folks that are an
aggregate that you can't avoid it is
unlike Vic I don't have any faith in
electing presidents who are better than
congressmen I don't think they are
better than congressmen and frankly I
think it's dangerous to think of
presidents as being more courageous than
congressmen they just have better
speechwriters and better makeup I think
that the congressmen collectively are
more accurate reflecting the country and
what you've got I have in my judgment is
you've got to have a political system
that holds us accountable and at that
point I think somebody's going to bite
the bullet if it even if it takes three
or four cycles of defeat to finally get
to a party that's willing to do it but
Newt on that point of accountability you
know the fact the matter is there's this
enormous dissatisfaction in the country
with government you talked about it
yourself great frustration with the way
things are going and yet 96 to 97
percent of all House members who run for
re-election get reelected not this year
well close to it not that far off I mean
but but when a woman loses and raddimus
loses those are because of special
situation but the basic fundamental
long-term average percentage of past
memories well over 90 percent who want
to get reelected get reelected I mean
the president United States is the one I
think who most accurately reflects broad
fundamental shifts in public opinion I
think that and is the most dangerous
well but see if you can be concerned
about danger but it seems to me that in
times of great national peril in the
past whether we talk about the Civil War
or we talk about FDR during the
depression of World War two we have
basically responded as a society to
those crises by having the president
whoever he was assumed authority that
was extraordinary
and it seems to me if you're as
concerned as I am about the 1980s then
we're talking about a situation again
when at a minimum at a minimum we have
to reduce the trend of the last few
years where we've undermined
presidential authority rather than
granted him additional authority dick I
know
would none of us I don't think we want
to come back keep coming back at you as
the point man right on this but I just I
find it it I'm just very surprised about
what you said about the president being
the most sensitive to a public opinion I
mean the United States conroy broad
national opinion this is far more close
to Betsy he doesn't even have any way of
doing that I mean he can walk around
with a bunch of polls that may be
outdated a week later depending on the
international events but one of the
reasons that Jimmy Carter got beat I can
say this coming from Georgia is that he
did not understand that the people
closest to the people in this country
the elected officials closest to the
people were the men and women the United
States Congress we are the eyes and ears
we are the ones that are home every
weekend we are the ones that are on the
ground sitting and listening to little
old ladies telling how their Social
Security check has just been eaten alive
by inflation concern about immigrants
coming into Florida worried about people
starving across the ocean but also
having real conflicts as to what I sit
spend my money when I don't have any
money to do it
but are we capable million are we
capable of making policy decisions to do
anything about it and the answer
obviously is no we can't even pass a
budget well see I don't well I would
whether that's a overall policy decision
is I think got the discussion but I'm
not willing to concede or we all all go
home that we cannot along the lines that
Newt was discussing find a way
I'll put I'll give the other side of the
argument but giving the same thing as
Newt was saying not so much that we have
a program that helps everybody in a
certain way I think that's one of the
problems that we've gotten into a
parceling out the goodies the American
American people will support a policy in
my opinion if they at least know they'll
if they know it hurts but if they know
that everybody is getting hurt equally
that everybody is sacrificing that
you're not exempted because you live on
this side of the street or at a certain
income or have a certain special
interest group working for you but where
we develop a common goal and say look
it's going to hurt but
if you want to be energy-independent if
you want to get the inflation down if
you want to get off of these national
deficits then we all got to sacrifice in
some way I don't think it needs to be
done in the tone of a national malaise
this way President Carter put but you
know as a Roosevelt in Wilson Teddy
Roosevelt your Roosevelt not ours policy
of how we get from here to there and
what we all have got to do to accomplish
it the problem I would suggest to mr.
Cheney here and to people who look to a
president is that the central purpose of
politics in a free society is to be an
arena in which somebody has a vision
which they communicate well enough that
enough different interest in Madison's
term that enough different interests
come together to pass that vision and
that the gravest danger we face since
Franklin Roosevelt is the perennial
pursuit of a personality that can
transcend by management and
administration the political job of
knitting together a majority in the
House and Senate and knitting together a
majority in the country and preaching a
change that will help enough people and
it can you can help them by stopping
inflation you can help them by new
opportunities but what worries me
precisely about I think the mindset of
the near future is the danger that this
administration will decide the well it's
conservative and economic philosophy it
is in fact radically liberal in a
willingness to accrue power and I think
that strong presidents are inherently
and fundamentally dangerous to this
society because they short-circuit the
political education of saying this is my
vision for the 80s this is where we have
to go this is why I want your vote and
if we don't do that kind of work in the
House and the Senate and thereby in the
country there's white she's right we're
the ones that go back then I think we
shouldn't have changes because it'll
undermine the whole fabric of society
let me just trail onto that a moment I
think Jimmy Carter's greatest failing
with Congress was his inability to
communicate effectively and consistently
and on a regular basis with the members
of his own party in the Congress I'm new
here I have not seen a lot of
congressional liaison operations
in my view this was not a good one
because it did not carry on that kind of
consistent communication I'm not saying
that if it had been done that a great
majority would have fallen in line on
these tough votes that would have had to
have been taken but I agree with Newt
that the Congress can work I agree with
him that the budget process while it has
a lot of feelings right now is a
significant step forward and can really
reach its promise but it will take
inventive creative leadership from the
president
and a lot of creative leadership within
the Congress which I think exists there
and can be brought into into bloom but
clearly it's not there now and then
maybe it hasn't been for some time let's
come down to some of the nuts and bolts
of what you have been putting on the
table here as critical to the formation
of public policy that will give us a
more confident in constructive future
among public policy goals which have
been widely discussed or higher defense
spending lower inflation and significant
tax cuts now can we really achieve any
of these goals in any real near-term I
think John is extremely important when
we talk about those first goals that you
have to put them within some kind of
time perspective I think we've got to
talk in terms of a two or three or four
year period of time and the bottom line
in my mind is that we are not going to
be able to meet our defense needs and
we're not going to be able to meet our
domestic needs unless we do in fact
reinvigorate the American economy
without real economic growth we simply
aren't going to be able to meet our
public policy obligations let alone take
care of the private sector - I think you
have to reach priorities I think that's
what dick is saying I would put the
highest priority on controlling
inflation because I think short of doing
that everything else falls apart I think
that takes among other things a
restrained fiscal policy creative
effective energy policy and a lot of
things happening the private sector in
terms of productivity and management
labor relations
and a number of other things that are
not happening at this time I think
without addressing that problem is the
number one priority everything else will
fall away I think if we can achieve a
solution to that problem effectively in
five to ten year period which is what I
think it will take we can then begin to
effectively address the other questions
that have been put on the table I think
Margaret Thatcher's experience well we
are not England is a good thing to look
at in seeing how long it's going to take
and how difficult it will be first of
all I think that the major problem in
this country economically is increasing
productivity increasing investment
increasing new technology because I
think if you produce enough things over
time they mop up the extra money I think
that if you try to control inflation the
way we've tried to for the last 20 years
it's politically impossible in the
society you cannot squeeze inflation out
of a democracy because in the long run
squeezing it out squeezes the public the
public won't stand for it and if the
Republican leadership and the Reagan
administration tried to squeeze
inflation out by severe cuts in spending
or by severe cuts in terms of monetary
policy what are you gonna see I think as
a democratic landslide in 1982 it is not
possible as Margaret Thatcher is proving
to squeeze a free society in two years
severely enough to change the inflation
rate what you've got to do instead is
change the tax code encourage businesses
to invest in new computer systems new
productivity systems new factories so
that there's enough extra productivity
that you can both buy the defense we
need and by the additional homes and the
additional goodies and pay the taxes I
think to to at that point balance the
budget ripped info up that's not going
to work I say with great respect to my
colleague one of the problems is of
course I mean everybody is for
increasing productivity in certain
industries I think Dick Gephardt and
those of us on ways and means you will
see targeted tax credits exemptions
aids for American industry that will
enable them to compete more effectively
but the problem with that philosophy is
that
you know all the world knows how to make
everything that we make now used to be
that we could just gear up production
and we could make all these things and
nobody else made them but everybody the
world knows how to make plastic buckets
and electric toothbrushes and color
television sets and they're making them
and we can produce all we want and find
that they're just not markets for them
and I of course on the international
scene part of the balance of payments
the delicacy of what I mentioned at
first of some international agreements
is a recognition of the fact that in the
production of all these things that they
produce and sell do they get the foreign
exchange to buy a lot of our excess
wheat and many of them many of the
monies that come back into our country
so I would like to think that simply the
testing of that philosophy you know if
we set the pecans ian's aside now we're
going to go over and say if we just
start producing everything again all of
a sudden I kind of our economy is going
to sing but I don't see any any evidence
of that though I think that certainly
that will be the direction that this new
Congress goes in well economics are
known as the dismal science but even
there nowadays I think you tend to hear
in these problems you'll find so
critical in the statement of priorities
with which you open this question of the
economy inflation and the budget you
find in in basic economics they talk
about expectations inflationary
expectations perhaps more dangerous than
any of the specific causes which bring
about inflation because the public
expects it now does the Congress have
the means and the will to try to
persuade the American people that
inflation is going to be brought under
control to you do you feel that you did
it for instance with respect to energy
policy how long did it take the American
people to discover we had an energy
problem and do they have really
understand it yet John the problem with
that whole line of thinking frankly is
that we're a free society and that
people generally speaking are reasonably
bright and that they look
all the different indicators and all the
different news shows and all the
different advertising and they make up
their own minds and if they look at a
country floundering towards 20 percent
interest rates they say to themselves
aha
prices are going up they don't care what
the Council of Economic Advisors says or
what the Ways and Means Committee says
or what the president exhorts in his
latest speech because they're not stupid
and we have had a consistent series of
advice from economists over the years
based on the assumption that the public
is dumber than they are which I think
given the track record is hard to prove
you know I think that we would frankly
be better off literally to ignore a can
I say this is a historian and maybe have
a bias in that sense but I think that
economics is not Leben the dismal
science it's been the irrelevant science
if we went back to the fundamentals
people produce more when they get more
money for producing it they produce less
when they get less money for producing
it and just ignored most of what we've
invented with computers in the last 20
years in economics this would be a far
healthier country and we wouldn't be
trying to outguess the American people
anybody else what to tackle that one you
know a lot like that you like that all
right let me come back yes I don't like
good I think he's right when he says
they watch what we do rather than what
we say or what's happening rather than
what we're saying I don't think you can
talk people out of an inflationary
psychology I think over a 5 or 10 year
period you can convince them that it's
not an inflationary time I don't go as
far as Newt does and what you can do on
the supply side I think it's a good
theory I think we've been hung up on
consumption and haven't worried about
production for too long I just don't go
as far as he does I think you have to
balance it with concern about
consumption and concern about your
fiscal policy and I just wouldn't get as
carried away as as he does and others in
his party do about what you can
accomplish on that score but I think
there's a great deal of truth than what
he's saying
all right let's come in from another
direction if we redirect a substantial
portion of our resources to national
defense what specific areas will we
redirect these resources away from well
you there's no magic in the budget if
you are far a restrained budget which
comes to as close to balance as you can
get with all the things we want to do
there's only one place to take the money
and that's from domestic programs and
more specifically it has to come from
some entitlement programs that dick
talked about there are not enough of
what we can call controllable which is
really a misnomer but everything is
controlled on the budget but we have
called a series of domestic programs
that are not Social Security or not
disability payments are not black lung
payments and what have you as
controllable programs there are not
enough of those in my view to to cut a
budget to get near balance so you've got
to look at Social Security you've got to
look at disability you've got to look at
some of the welfare programs in addition
to health and education and the other
so-called controllable items if you're
to free up money
significant money which I think you have
to do for defense yeah I would point out
I guess if you you know if you go back
to the peacetime 50s when Dwight
Eisenhower was president or for the
early years of the Kennedy
administration when we were at pieces of
country we spent close to 11 percent of
our gross national product every year on
defense
1979 we spent less than 5 percent of our
gross national product on defense and
during that same period of time while we
were reducing our overall percentage of
GNP on defense we went roughly from $2
out of every 4 in the federal budget for
defense to $1 out of every 4 roughly for
defense simultaneously with that we
diverted resources into the domestic
area we adopted the Great Society
programs added the disability program to
Social Security I looked up the numbers
the other day on on the disability
program when it was set up in 1956 they
estimated that by 1980 there would be 1
million people eligible for benefits and
it would cost 860 million dollars a year
the reality in 1980 was that it didn't
cost 860 million it costs 17 billion
dollars and there were five million
people involved to the one there's been
an enormous growth in the domestic side
and I think obviously what you're
talking about is a reality
creation of those resources not to the
extent that we're gonna cut back below
the level we're already spending in an
area but that future growth in the
budget is going to have to come in the
defense area while simultaneously we put
the brakes to the increased spending in
the non-defense area and obviously
you're gonna have to address I think
some of the entitlement programs
representing great John I mean if I can
comment on one of the premises of your
question I'm not certain despite all the
rhetoric that we need to spend
dramatically more on defense although
I'm a hawk in most ways I am certain
that we need to spend our money
differently on defense and I think one
of the places that the president ought
to be looking at to change the budget
and rather than cut it is inside the
Pentagon I think that there is
incredible amount of waste and lack of
effective management in the military and
I think that we have a set of
assumptions strategically that are
nonsense in the present age and that we
could completely rethink the way we're
doing things and I have a great fear
that we're going to in effect spend
let's say eight percent of GNP instead
of five feel that we are thereby more
safe and in fact build imagine a line
behind which we accomplish nothing I
don't see right now any automatic
increased security for America by
blindly throwing money into the Pentagon
and hoping that that scares the Russians
now I think on managing the budget which
is a different issue the Ronald Reagan
would do well to study the career of
Gladstone they spent 40 years being a
pinchpenny in Britain and convinced the
entire middle class that he looked after
their dollars and that if he didn't have
to spend them in the government he gave
him back to them so they could spend
them on their own families I think you
start frankly with massive
decentralization you take virtually
every government grant program you lump
it into five or six categorical programs
and you give all that money back and in
a year either in a block grant not
category you give all that money back to
the state of Georgia and you say in the
state legislature figure out how to
spend you know what we used to give you
in 27 different grants and you eliminate
in this city and you have a real estate
depression in Washington because you
shift the bureaucracy out of Washington
and the decision-making out of
Washington back into state and local
government I think that alone would
probably save us literally something in
the order of 10 to 20 billion dollars in
budget we'd like to hear from the other
side of Georgia
well John first of all we have got to in
this country come up with a redefinition
of Defense
I mean defense is just not more and more
missiles and more and more technological
systems defense is getting off a ninety
billion dollar heroin like habit on
imported energy which is threatening our
national security because of our
propagation and energy you said in its
relationship to the rest of the world
defense is making defense is taking some
real risk in foreign policy that we have
had problems in the Congress reaching
any even the beginnings of consensus
either within our party or in league
with the Republicans I mean when Robert
Mugabe who campaigns as a Marxist then
comes to Washington and says look we
have a freely elected government in
Zimbabwe we don't want the Russians in
there but we need your help to the tune
of thirty five forty five million
dollars not billion million to try to
help us keep the Russians out we don't
want them they just take over your
country we want to follow your
westernized trends and we said we shut
the door
same in Nicaragua nobody knows whether
or not they're going to go running to
the Russians one year or two years or
two weeks later but the point is you've
got to take some risk around the world
to make some friends that will be your
allies in difficult times we can't we
could spend until the cows come home and
we could not field an army on the Soviet
border to protect either Afghanistan or
Poland in my opinion we could spend till
the cows come home with all sorts of new
technological systems and if we had to
draw the line in the Horn of Africa
either in and around Ethiopia Somalia
Djibouti we could not do it because we
look at defense spending only in terms
of new Trident submarines and mx and all
the technological gadgets and ignore the
rest of the world
who are rapidly choosing size to say we
either want to be on the side of the
United States because they're our friend
or we'd like to go over to the Soviets
because they help us when we need help
in this whole area of foreign policy
which I'm glad you raised and public
policy do you see a new direction and
perhaps a more effective and efficient
use of public policy in the field of
Foreign Affairs in the reaction to
Afghanistan and the Polish crises in
1980 ie and almost acceptance that we
are militarily incapable of acting but
that we will organize such economic
punishment and public relations
punishment that we could perhaps stop
the Soviet ambitions do you find this a
new approach and effective approach mr.
Gingrich John you've you've covered a
lot of this over the years and there has
always been despite the occasional
headlines an American assumption that we
had neither the interest the desire nor
the will to exert military power within
reach of the Soviet border we never
under Eisenhower Kennedy anyone thought
that we could help pull them
Franklin Roosevelt didn't think we could
help Pollan and basically made a deal
and that's always been our policy that
Poland will be as free as the Soviet
Union allows it to be we have no
interest in a bacin in Afghanistan at
the present time have never had any and
I think that you have to look very
carefully of what we want to accomplish
with our policy we have defended Europe
very Abele I might I think and very
cheaply for 35 years now on the
assumption that if you keep a large
enough garrison army there and enough
dependents there that a Soviet invasion
of Europe means nuclear war and that
there are no risk they'll take leading
nuclear war now we've defended Japan
under exactly the same premise and then
on occasion we have stumbled into
various and sundry secondary Wars
Vietnam being the the least admirable
example both an efficiency and maybe in
wisdom I think we have to think through
our policies and we're you know we're
currently not doing it what has happened
in the last two years is the largest
swing in public opinion since 1939 what
we have seen is a general view
I think not that we're inferior per se
but that military force makes a
difference and I think in that sense the
invasion of Afghanistan the Iranian
crisis which I think had much more to do
with our nationalism right now than
Afghanistan and finally Poland do mean
that there's a broad public feeling that
the world is dangerous and we have to be
capable of surviving in it I think
that's where wrap grab significant well
I think the actions taken by the
president with regard to the Soviet
Union after Afghanistan were a departure
in public policy to some extent from
what we've done in the past it was an
exertion of linkage if you will in the
Soviet relationship it was an attempt to
treat their bad behavior with punishment
I think it had an effect will it stop
them from going into Poland probably not
but did it have an effect I think it did
and I think it was a constructive effect
and I think we all however agree that
having sufficient military power as one
of our foreign policy tools is
absolutely necessary and that since
Vietnam whether we like it or not we've
allowed that military machine to fall
into a certain state of disrepair which
has to be remedied all right I think
that we have opened up this whole issue
of the possibilities of future we've
certainly decided the possibilities for
revitalizing America are numerous but
that the achievement of the goals is
going to be a hard road and it's time
for us to have a question-and-answer
session may I have the first question
please I'm Howard pennyman and I'm from
American Enterprise Institute in
Georgetown University could I go back to
some of the very early discussion the
question of whether people represent
their district or represent the United
States is an old question Woodrow Wilson
said as far as that century ago that
American congressman represented their
district and not the nation as a whole
every basic reform whether it be to
change the electoral system or to reform
the Congress has tended to further
fragment and decentralize the Congress
one of the results is it
to me and I'd like to ask all of you to
comment on it is that it has so made
congressman represent their districts
that they both a believe deeply in
cutting the budget and be in never
cutting it where it would hurt anybody
among those who have interests in their
districts I do like to start with that
you look like a good old brave and well
I I think most of us attempt to achieve
some kind of balance I mean after you've
campaigned for a year or two years or in
the case of mr. Gingrich from Georgia
three separate times and before you win
you feel that you have a common identity
with your constituents and I think most
members probably when it comes time to
cast a vote on a key issue rarely feel a
tug between on the one hand so-called
national interest and on the other hand
district interest you rationalize in
their own mind that what your
constituents want and what you want is
what's right for the country it's those
fellows on the other side that are
representing the special interest in
their districts so that the choice in
the mind of the congressman I think is
really framed and though in those
clear-cut terms I think your your
attitude toward voting is in large part
dependent upon your last majority if you
won by 50.000 zero one percent I think
you keep her ear pretty close to the
ground in preparation for the next
campaign if you won by ninety five
percent of the vote I think you vote
fairly freely according to you the
dictates of your conscience whether that
be in line with your district and what
it thinks and what the majority thinks
or what would be seen as a national
position
Irishman Chinese position about giving
authority to the president to carry out
the cuts which you talked about all
right let me make a comment because it
did I don't know
political science has done an enormous
disservice to government in this country
because it is almost completely a
historical the founding fathers
deliberately designed one branch of the
government to be permanently scared and
that's why they have them run every two
years it is a deliberate design function
they specifically want us to speak for
the district and they have the rather
naive belief that if a president can't
find 218 districts that gain more than
they lose from a particular bill that
that bill that will be defeated now I
think by George you're supposed to speak
for the people of your district because
that's who you understand that's who you
represent and that you collectively as
the house represent the country and I
think any congressman who gets up and
says well this will destroy my district
economically but in the national
interest I want to do that is in fact
betraying their specific commitment in
the Constitution and I find it very
frankly naive and destructive in the
long run to keep favoring a general good
which has no specific good because I
don't think there is a general good for
the country as a whole which you can't
piece together in 218 districts but Newt
wouldn't you agree then on that basis
and I think this goes back to to the
question that was asked that given the
constitutional arrangement given our
mandate as congressman to represent our
districts that in looking for that spark
that dynamic spark or leadership or
initiative that is going to set the
agenda and helps all the problems we
have to look to the presidency that that
is more likely to be the arena in which
the answers are found than in the
Congress specifically and precisely in
the Federalist Papers and in almost all
the writing the founding fathers a
concern that we have effective
leadership in the Congress because it is
among the congressmen that you should
make the compromises and the
understandings and the level of
political sophistication necessary both
to manage the people who we pay the
bureaucrats and to rearrange the
legislation for our constituents and it
is the failure of our generation to
produce effective political and
congressional leaders in
Congress that leads us I think to the
very grave danger in the long run of
tyranny we would be most interested to
hear from you thank you Miss Bingley
attorney well I think it may be naive
and I will admit to that but to to
respond to mr. Gingrich what we need in
the United States Congress are men and
women who are not afraid to lose who do
not see this as a lifelong profession to
serve this a constituency so so readily
and only that constituency in every
little whim of public policy that the
breeze may blow to simply perpetuate
them in office now I know that it's a
lot easier to say than to do if they're
going to close a military base in your
district to build a more modern one
somewhere else
that is in the national interest to do
so it is not in the economic interest of
that members district that's when you
earn your pay to vote to close it in
your district in order to achieve the
national interest to modernize your
defense establishment I mean these
questions have been debated but we are
not 535 men and women are not city
councilmen we're not state legislatures
we shouldn't be Ward politicians
catering to whatever sense of
information and purpose that comes on a
weekly basis or you will never mold any
national policy but the problem is that
we won't stay here so most of us are
afraid to vote on any given issue in
something that's too brave because then
we get thrown out next time can I go
back on it I think the question is
perhaps not as well put as it could be
most issues don't break down very neatly
as I think dick said into a district
interest in an ash
interest it breaks down between what you
perceive as being both in the interest
of your district in and the national
interest and an interest group that is
usually represented in your constituency
let's take the example of the twice a
year Cola for federal retirees the
cost-of-living adjustment I think most
members probably felt that that was a a
change making it a once a year
cost-of-living adjustment was a change
that was in order that was legitimate
inappropriate but each of us had three
or five or six thousand federal retirees
sitting in our district writing letters
making telephone calls and so people a
lot of people before an election did not
want to vote against that large group
when you're winning by a thousand or
three thousand or six thousand votes
that to me is is the way a lot of issues
are presented and I don't think it
breaks down as neatly as perhaps your
question suggests I marry the next
question please yes sir I'm John Hellman
I'm from the University of Washington in
Seattle and AEI and I relaying a
question as chairman of a Department of
Political Science from my students
because I've been quite amazed to hear
four congressmen talk about revitalizing
America without directly addressing the
question of revitalizing Congress the
mood if I may repeat my students is that
Washington is a subculture that
congressmen do not act as statesmen they
simply represent those interests that
have access to them be they local
constituents or Washington interest
groups they rarely transcend the
immediate they do not provide a basis
for leadership for the country I call to
your attention also repeated public
opinion polls expressing approval which
rarely exceeds 30 percent of the
performance of the role of Congress and
one taken in the early well I guess
about 1974 where congressmen were rated
above trash collectors and below barbers
in terms of professional respect I would
like to raise the question to all of you
I what is wrong and do you think
anything can be done to alter the image
of Congress because the perception out
there is not that you are doing a superb
job but that somehow you are doing a job
that must be done but not doing it very
well mr. father has volunteered well let
me let me wait in where angels fear to
tread for your students to say that
first I would say to your students that
in a free society and a representative
system that you get the kind of
government that you deserve if you
tolerate apathy and your public
officials you get apathy if you tolerate
corruption then you get corruption
because we are still a government by the
government by those students and the
people in this room and people
throughout the country the Congress will
never be any greater in its
statesmanship than the values and the
hopes and the demands of the American
people we have the same faults they are
certain because we are representative
and come from a system where we are
elected every two years we mirror those
hopes and those aspirations and those
faults that means you get a certain
number of blue-eyed people you get a
certain number of alcoholics you get a
certain number of any other trend that
you want to put on your computer but
back to the question that we discussed
before the real question is in a
pluralistic society where you've got
black people and Spaniards and rich
people and poor people how on any given
vote can you be truly representative I
represent a district that's 50% black
and 50% white a district where the gap
between the number of high income people
a number of low income people that gap
in between is greater than any other
congressional district in the country
according to all these computer
operators so the question that I would
ask to your students is how can you be
on any
vote truly representative you can't I
know that on any given vote I'm not
going to make 50% of them mad but
probably 80% of them man when I cast a
vote that I deemed to be in the national
interest but you have to turn this
question back in a free society to the
people who are the electorate because
they are the government in this country
and again they're going to get what they
deserve in their representatives in
Washington sorry I think Congress itself
has to bear a great deal of the blame
for the way government's perceived
because we probably do as much
communicating as anybody in America
today next to the Walter Cronkite and
the people on this on the evening news
shows we send out newsletters we make
speeches we visit with our constituents
to the extent that the American people
have a perspective on government I think
to some extent we're responsible for
having created that we created by
castigating the courts and condemning
the bureaucracy and worrying about
alleged abuses of presidential power by
presidents and we also I think have
failed in a very important perspective
being reflective about what our role in
our responsibilities is yes we do have
to be representative yes we do have to
pass appropriations bills and conduct
oversight but we don't debate the great
issues of the day we spend hours and
hours and hours on absolutely idiotic
procedural questions we don't get into
the basic fundamental issues that I
think the American people often feel
ought to be the central concern of their
government and to some extent we brought
it on ourselves thank your students are
probably basically right I think that
there are two instances or two
conditions which will change the
condition of Congress one is if more of
your students will take it upon
themselves to run for Congress rather
than going into the business world to
make a big buck or secondly if we have a
catastrophe in the country and people
really begin to worry about what
Congress is doing is Dick said 95% of us
get reelected if we're not exerting
leadership
and the American people don't want
leadership because they're reelecting
people that your students they are not
giving them leadership I think as long
as things were going along relatively
well and they have been for 40 or 50
years up until about the last ten nobody
really cared and coming except for the
cadet you both you because you're both
Democrats and just went through a tough
election in terms of your party at large
it seems to me that one of our great
problems is that that each of us is
individually perceived as a very
effective representative that the
problem is that Congress in the
aggregate is not able to function in
with some anti synergism whatever that
word is that we bring together each of
the 435 parts and we somehow become less
than the sum of the whole and I think
that's been one of our great problems
we're all much better as individuals
than we are as a team you know I run
around my district and I looked at this
high school that I used to go to the
public high schools I couldn't figure
out how it was different it looked
different I could tell I couldn't it
took me 20 minutes of looking at it and
all of a sudden I realized that it was
this one tremendous parking lot around
it we didn't have cars 20 years ago when
I went to high school now everybody's
got their own car so when your students
start worrying about whether or not why
we don't have an effective energy policy
in this country ask them how many of
them would be willing to be statesmen
and give up those cars until we got our
imported oil bill down from ninety
billion dollars a year to ten million
dollars a year and we'll test
statesmanship at both ends but why
scheisse I sense that your students are
asking for tough leadership decisions
like a gas tax John Anderson was very
popular on college campuses he talked
about tough solutions to tough problems
and I think what you're saying is that
that's what they're asking for and I
would just suggest back that that will
happen when either we have a catastrophe
and then people demand those kinds of
things happen or will
to have a consensus form in that in that
regard or until we get 219 people in the
house and 51 people in the Senate who
perceived that that kind of thing I'm
not saying that's necessarily a right
policy but those kinds of things are
necessary to do should go ahead and
endorse my policy on the far the gas tax
I voted for at one point final remark
the students want to believe I think
that is an interesting point enrollments
in political science are up 50 60
percent over the last two years and the
interest in governance and governmental
institutions is truly growing and
Anderson's appeal was very substantial
around altruistic symbols I think the
complaint about Congress is they they
don't find inspiration they don't find
something there that they can look to as
more than a mirror of the society maybe
it can't be more than that but that's
that's somehow what they want anybody
else wants to talk to this what if in
fact the reason we are floundering
around in the Congress is because the
country is floundering around what if in
fact it is the nature of a free society
to take long periods to talk to itself
to sort things out to move slowly so as
not to crush any single group and that
one of the things that our students are
going to have to learn in the long run
is that to be free there's on occasion
to be impatient to be frustrated and
have to work awfully hard to get
anything done because that is in fact
precisely what freedom takes I think in
that sense if you look at our record
compared to Nazi Germany or compared to
Soviet Russia we don't do all that bad a
job over 20 years although certainly we
do a terrible job over one year all
right this concludes another public
policy forum presented by the American
Enterprise Institute for Public Policy
Research on behalf of AEI our hearty
thanks to the distinguished and expert
panelists congressman Newt Gingrich
Richard bee trainee Richard Gephardt and
wife Ella and of course also to our
guests at experts in the audience for
their participation
it is the aim of AEI to clarify issues
of the day by presenting many viewpoints
in the hope that by doing so those who
wish to learn about the decision-making
process will benefit from such a free
exchange of informed and enlightened
opinion this public policy forum series
is created and supplied to this station
as a public service by the American
Enterprise Institute Washington DC a AEI
is a nonprofit nonpartisan publicly
supported research and education
organization
information on this and other subject
areas including government regulation
economic policy Social Security and
retirement health policy legal policy
tax policy political and social
processes energy policy defense policy
and international affairs is available
from the Institute for a transcript of
this program send $3.75 to the American
Enterprise Institute 11:50 17th Street
Northwest Washington DC 2 0 0 3 6
you
[Music]